the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok guys hope you enjoyed the the brief
break from the heavy technical stuff cuz
we're gonna get right back into it and
developed the neutron transport equation
today the one that you see on
everybody's t-shirts here in the
department so I think multiple years
folks have used this equation on the
back of t-shirts to just be like we're
awesome and we do difficult math well
this is when you're gonna start to do it
in fact it's big enough and hard enough
that we're gonna spend all day today
developing it like actually writing out
the terms of the equation and
understanding what it actually means
before on Thursday and Friday we're
going to reduce it down to a much
simpler equation something that you can
actually solve and do some simple
reactor calculations with we started off
the whole idea of the neutron transport
equation as a way to track some
population of neutrons see I'm gonna
have our variable list up here what I'll
probably do is on Thursday and Friday
I'll just have it back up on the screen
so that we don't have to write it twice
but there's gonna be a lot of variables
in this equation I'm gonna do my best
again to make the difference between V
and nu very obvious and anything else
like that but the goal is to track some
population of neutrons at some position
at some energy traveling in some
direction Omega as a function of time
and the 3d representation of what we're
looking at here is let's say we had some
small volume element which we'll call
that R DV that's got normal vectors
sticking out of it we'll call those n
hats in all directions and inside there
let's say if this is our energy scale
we're tracking the population of
neutrons that occupy some small energy
group de and is also traveling in some
small direction that we designate as D
Omega so that's the goal of this whole
equation is to track the number of
neutrons at any given position so let's
call this distance
or the vector are in this little volume
traveling in some direction Omega with
some infinitesimally small energy group
D that's gonna be the goal of the whole
thing and what we'll do is write this to
say the change in the population of
neutrons at a given distance energy
angle and time over time is just gonna
be a sum of gain and loss terms and what
I think will take all day today to do is
to figure out what are the actual
physical things that neutrons can do in
and out of this volume and how do we
turn those into math something that we
can abstract and solve there's a couple
other terms that we're going to put up
here we'll say that the flux of neutrons
which is usually the variable that we
actually track is just the velocity
times the neutron population and also
let's define some angular ly independent
terms because in the end we've been
talking about what's the probability of
some neutron or particle interacting
with some electron going out at some
angle but as we're interested in how
many neutrons are there in the reactor
we usually don't care in which direction
they're traveling so the first
simplification that we will do is get
rid of any sort of angular dependence
getting rid of two of the seven
variables that we're dealing with here
so all these variables right here will
be dependent on angle and all these
variables right here will be angular ly
and you literally independence
so there'll be some corresponding
capital N or number of neutrons as a
function of re and T will call this flux
we'll call this number
there's going to be a number of
cross-sections that we need to worry
about so we'll refer to little Sigma as
a function of energy as our micro cross
section and big Sigma of e as a
macroscopic cross section then you want
to remember the relation between these
two the solid angle not quite that's
let's see there's a difference between
and so what these physically mean as
little Sigma means the probability of
interaction with one particle and this
is just a total probability of
interaction with all the particles that
may be there so yeah Chris there's
number density already we have another
variable conflict how do we want to
resolve this let's see I'll have to
change the symbol somehow let's make it
cursive don't know what else to do I
don't want to give it a number other
than n since we're talking about
neutrons where that right here is going
to be number density and in the end
we're worried about some sort of
reaction rate which is always going to
equal some flux or let's just stick with
some angular ly dependent flux at re
Omega T times some cross-section as a
function of energy and it's these
reaction rates that are the rates of
gains and losses of neutrons out of this
volume out of this little angle out of
this energy group and out of that space
or into that volume energy group in
space so let's see other terms that
we'll want to define
include new like last time we'll call
this Neutron multiplication in other
words this is the number of neutrons
made on average during each fission
event and we give it energy dependence
because as we saw on the Janus libraries
on Friday I think it was what's today
Tuesday I don't even know anymore I
think as we saw on Friday that depends
on energy for the higher energy levels
and there's also going to be some kaiser
or some neutron birth spectrum which
tells you the average energy at which
neutrons are born from fission so
regardless of what energy goes in to
cause the fission there's some
probability distribution of a neutron
being born at a certain energy and it
looks something like this where that's
about one MeV that's about ten MeV and
that average right there is around two
MeV and so it's important to note that
neutrons are born at different energies
because we want to track every single
possible de throughout this control
volume which we'll also call a reactor
let's say what other terms will we need
to know the different types of
cross-sections are the different
interactions that neutrons can have with
matter what are some of the ones that we
had talked about well what can neutrons
do when they run into stuff they can
scatter so there's going to be some
scattering cross-section and when they
scatter the important part here is
they're going to change in energy
what else can they do
yep they can be absorbed so we'll have
some Sigma absorption what are some of
the various things that can happen when
a neutron is absorbed yep so one of them
is fission what are some of the other
ones yep
capture over some of the ones that we
talked about during the Chadwick paper
yep so there can be some we'll call it n
I n
one Neutron goes in i neutrons come out
so one two i neutrons sure anything else
encompassed and absorption
well when we refer to scatter here what
type of scattering are we talking about
Compton's for photons it's okay
was it elastic or inelastic scattering
elastic scattering so another thing you
could call an absorption event depending
on what bin you put things in is
inelastic scattering which is that kind
of skites we call it scattering because
one Neutron goes in one neutron comes
out but in reality you have a compound
nucleus forming and a neutron emitted
from a different energy level so it
doesn't follow the simple ballistic laws
of an kinematic laws of inelastic
scattering what else can neutrons do now
we're getting into the real esoteric
stuff but I want to see if you guys have
any idea did you know that neutrons can
decay a lone Neutron is actually not a
stable particle if you look up on the
Kairi table of nuclides it's got a
half-life of 12 minutes so if you happen
to be able to have neutrons in a bottle
or something which we actually can do
there's Centers for ultracold neutrons
and atoms there's there's one at North
Carolina State or they actually cool
down neutrons to cryogenic temperatures
to the point where they can actually
confine them they only live on average
12 minutes and then there would also be
what we call Neutron Neutron
interactions there is a finite non zero
but very small probability that neutrons
can hit other neutrons but the mean free
path for these is on the order of 10 to
the 8th centimeters so this is not
something we have to consider but it's
interesting to know that yes neutrons
can run into other neutrons and these
sorts of things have been measured we
won't have to worry about this we won't
have to worry about neutron decay but it
interesting to note that a lone Neutron
is not a stable particle it'll
spontaneously undergo beta decay and do
it a proton and an electron pretty neat
huh anyway if we sum up all these
possible interactions we have one other
cross-section which we're going to call
this the total cross-section the
probability of absolutely any
interaction occurring at all because any
sort of interaction of that Neutron is
going to cause removal from this group
of energy position angle location
whatever whether it's absorption or
fission or elastic scattering or
inelastic scattering any sort of event
except for forward scattering which
means nothing happens is going to result
in this neutron either leaving the
volume so it might scatter out of our
little volume or it might change
direction scatter out of our D Omega or
it will lose some energy or gain some
energy in some cases leaving our little
d e which is what we're trying to track
because we're actually tracking what's
the population of neutrons in this
little de in this direction in this
position at this time and supposedly if
we know this term fully we can solve for
all the neutrons everywhere anywhere in
the reactor with full information so
we'll spend the rest of today doing is
figuring out what are all the possible
gain and loss terms so let's start just
putting them out physically or in words
and then we'll put them to math so what
are some of the ways in which neutrons
can enter our little group of volume
angle and energy our neutrons created
yeah Luke
some vision yep so that's one big source
so we'll call this a games this is the
losses and you said a neutron source can
you be more specific
okay so we'll say n I end reactions
right okay cool
how else can we gain neutrons fusion
okay ah that is true although fusion
reactors don't really operate on the
principle of neutron criticality or
Neutron balance so this discussion for
now is gonna be limited to fission
reactors but yeah good point
fusion does make neutrons what else yeah
yeah they could come from somewhere else
right let's just call that an external
source in the books and in your reading
you'll just see them treat this external
source as some variable s of our e Omega
T so you'll just see this treated as s a
source with no further explanation it's
like oh math says that there could be
external sources but I want to tell you
where they really come from most
reactors nowadays don't just start up
when you throw a bunch of uranium into a
pool and pull out the control rods you
actually have to stick in if this is
your little reactor right here you
actually have to stick in a little piece
of californium I think the isotope is
252 as what we call a kick starter
source so californium is made mostly in
the high fer or the high flux isotope
reactor at the Oak Ridge National Lab in
Tennessee where they have a really
really high power reactor it's 85
megawatts it's about that big around and
this tall it's really really small for a
reference that's about the size of the
MIT reactor except our reactor six
megawatts there's as 85 megawatts and
it's designed to be an incredibly high
flux to go by Neutron capture and
neutron capture reactions to build up
californium to 52 which is spontaneously
giving off neutrons like crazy and this
right here that's your external source
and this helps get reactors going
because you can either very slowly wait
for the fission reaction to build up in
a controlled manner or you can give it a
kick in the pants and get it going this
hyper reactor is pretty cool like I said
it's 85 megawatts and it's about as
dense as it can get the fuels actually
made by explosively bonding sheets of
uranium in a certain sort of semi
cylindrical configuration and it
produces so much decay heat in so little
space that if it were to lose cooling
reactor would melt in eight seconds
usually have days or so before that
happens in a conventional reactor
because the power density just isn't
that high
so you can actually see down to the tank
that contains - if you go for a tour at
Oakridge National Lab and it's way down
below this gigantic like not quite
Olympic but get in there sized pool of
water just to make sure that there is
adequate cooling for this thing it's
intense but yeah that's just to notice
that these external sources these are
real things that we use in power
reactors to get them going what are some
other ways that one could make neutrons
or that neutrons could enter into our
energy group and the silence is expected
because this is usually the hardest part
of developing this equation and I want
to introduce it yeah Luke that's exactly
it they can scatter in so when we
develop this Neutron transport equation
we're not just tracking the neutrons in
this little energy group de Direction D
Omega and volume DV you actually have to
know what's the population of neutrons
at every single group because you might
have a neutron at a higher energy level
that undergoes scattering from some
different energy E Prime into our energy
group so continuing with our gigantic
list of variables we're going to call e
is I'll say our energy and this vector
Omega is our direction the one that
we're tracking and a prime is going to
be some other energy and Omega vector
prime is going to be some coming from
some other direction and like Luke said
this this is what we would refer to as
in scattering
which means some neutron comes that was
going in a different direction that did
have a different energy and has now
entered into the single group that we're
tracking eventually we're going to
integrate over all energies to track all
energy groups so that's where we're
going and there's one more term that I
want to introduce right now it's what's
called the scattering kernel don't ask
me why it's called kernel but this is
just the terminology I want you guys to
get used to and it's going to be some
sort of probability function where a
neutron starts off at a different energy
e Prime and in a different direction
Omega Prime and it enters into our group
energy E and Direction Omega right now
we'll leave it as a highly general
function what we're gonna find later is
there's just some sort of simple line to
it if you guys remember if some neutron
starts off let's say probability of
entering it to some energy group if you
notice if you remember from last time
the neutron when it undergoes any sort
of scattering reaction can end up with
any energy between its original energy
for the case of theta equals zero and
this parameter alpha energy for the case
theta equals PI where alpha is a minus 1
over a plus 1 squared where a is the
atomic mass you guys remember this from
back in the Q equation days when we were
finding out what's the probability that
a neutron coming in with energy e
ends up at any energy e prime what this
actually I'll just write this as the
scattering kernel what it ends up
looking like in most cases is just a
flat line there's an equal probability
of the neutron ending up anywhere
between energy E and anywhere between
energy alpha e it's actually a pretty
simple function it's just a constant
value here and zero everywhere else what
that means is that if let's say a
neutron hits a uranium atom there's no
way in hell that it can transfer all of
its energy to a uranium atom because of
conservation and energy and conservation
of energy and momentum like we've been
harping on for kind of this whole class
what's the only time that this alpha e
could actually extend all the way to
zero what case would that be you're
hitting another neutron which as we said
is a very rare event that is true or
what else could you be hitting a proton
hydrogen that's right so it can only be
let's say you can only have the
probability of the neutron coming ending
up with any energy for the case of
hydrogen incidentally this is why we
fill light water reactors with hydrogen
the goal is to get the neutrons as slow
as possible as quick as possible
interesting sentence to say there right
we want the neutrons to be as low energy
as possible as rapidly as possible and
the best way to do that is to fill the
reactor with hydrogen because then any
collision could in theory get the
neutron down to zero energy without
water or something with the same mass as
a neutron like another Neutron there's
no way that that Neutron can slow down
by very much so even though we're gonna
keep it as this generalized function
note that in reality it's this pretty
simple function it changes a little bit
as there can be a forward scattering
bias for some Neutron reactions but we
are not going to deal with that this
year you will deal with that next year
in 22:05 so I've been saying a lot oh
well we're not gonna go into this topic
because if you're gonna see it in 2202
which is quantum now I switch gears to
say we're not going to go into the way
this function changes cuz you'll see it
next year in 2205 which is Neutron
physics but for now I want you to be
prepared for 2205 so we'll put on in
scattering as one of our gains
there's a last one I want to make you
aware of we very briefly touched upon it
but I wouldn't be surprised if no one
remembers because it was for like ten
seconds it's what's called photo fission
what this means is you have some
reaction that would in comes a gamma and
out goes fission this actually does
start to happen around three or four MeV
for isotopes like uranium-235 and in our
reactor whatever whatever shape we
decide it is there are tons of gamma
rays flying about in all directions at
very high energy does anyone remember
where they come from anyone remember the
fission timeline that we drew on Friday
so what we said there was right away
let's say fission happens and almost
instantly you get your fission product
one and fission product two and they
move around for a little while
and then some of them will emit some
neutrons and then some of them will
start to emit gamma rays betas and
whatever else they're gonna do until
they finally lose all their kinetic
energy and stop in the surrounding fuel
creating the heat that actually powers
the turbine and makes steam to make
electricity and so it's from these
gammas as well as any of the gammas from
the decay products of the fission
products that lead to a huge flux of
gamma rays firing out from all sides in
the reactor that's one of the main
things that you actually have to shield
in a nuclear reactor since we talked
about all sorts of different shielding
and all sorts of ways that you have to
shield things you know from seeing the
MIT reactor which you all did that
there's like six feet of lead and
concrete shielding around the reactor
it's not there to shield the alphas and
the beta's because those don't really
make it out of the water it's not there
to shield the soft x-rays that betas
make from bremsstrahlung
it's also not there to shield the
neutrons because the neutrons don't
really get out they bounce around or get
absorbed in the water the fuel the
reflector it's there to shield the
high-energy gamma rays because the only
thing that stops high-energy gamma rays
is lots of mass in between the source
and you so we know there's tons of
gammas all about so let's say there's
also going to be some gamma ray flux
there'll be some gamma ray energy and
there'll be some cross-section for photo
fission as a function of the incoming
gamma ray energy spectrum now I'm adding
terms to the ones that you'll see in the
reading because drawing them out in math
is actually fairly instructive they all
follow the same pattern so instead of
just showing you one of each and saying
memorize we'll develop a whole lot of
these and you'll find out that they all
actually look almost the same anyone
else can anyone else think of any
possible gains of neutrons where else
could they come from yeah
so the neutron birth spectrum is
included in fission so our new is in
there our kya V is in there and that's a
new of II that's all accounted for in
the fission term and we'll see how we
put that together to math and if no one
else has any ideas that's good because
neither do I now what about the lost
terms there aren't too many of these as
long as you lump them correctly so what
sort of ways could neutrons be lost from
our energy group yep
scatter out yep they can undergo any
kind of scattering reaction and they
will probably change direction and
energy what else well we've got to lift
up on the board right there right
capture decision because in order to
undergo fission you actually have to
lose a neutron and so on and so on and
so on what I want to do to simplify
things is this it's a lot simpler just
to track the total cross-section the
probability of any interaction at all
whatsoever because any interaction will
cause the neutron to either change
energy and angle or disappear even if it
makes some other ones so we can simplify
this to just the total cross-section
term and there's only one other way that
neutrons can leave our energy angle and
volume group what would that be so any
reaction takes care of energy and angle
what about volume how did neutrons leave
the control volume
it's simpler than it may sound they just
go they just move the neutrons are
always moving right we'll call that
leakage because every neutrons got a
speed like we've showed up here where
the flux of neutrons the number of
neutrons moving through some surface per
second is just their velocity times the
number that are there for there to be a
neutron flux there has to be a velocity
which means the neutrons are moving so
the neutrons even without undergoing any
reaction could just move out of our
control volume and then they're gone and
that's all there is for gain and loss
terms so let's see if we can do this all
on one board I want to start putting
this table right here into math that
we'll be able to abstract simplify and
then solve but not today not solve today
so if we want to track the change in the
number of neutrons as a function of time
let's start writing down the gain terms
so how do we describe the number of
neutrons produced from fission what sort
of terms do we have to include and Jared
started kicking us off so what would you
say
yep so the neutron birth spectrum
there's going to be some probability
that a neutron is born in our energy
group e because we're tracking how many
neutrons are in our little de energy
group what else matters in terms of
fission yep number of fissions so if we
want to write number of fission's we
have to write that as a reaction rate so
let's take those two terms right there
so we'll have Sigma fission in this case
we're gonna write e prime times flux of
our e prime Omega prime T why did I
write in Omega prime here just from a
physical reason yeah precisely that's
right so the neutrons are going to be
produced from some other energy group
for example the fission birth spectrum
right here starts out where did it go I
knew I drew it somewhere at 1 MeV but
most of the neutrons that cause fission
to happen are way down below one easy so
it's different energy neutrons that
cause neutrons to be born in our energy
group that's why we're using a prime and
not e it's some other energy group and
so we also have to account for all
possible other energy groups so if we
want to write this right we'll say this
could be as low as 0 evey to our maximum
energy and there's going to be some D
Omega prime D prime D V we'll also have
to account for all possible angles and
integrate over our entire volume it's
get it's going to get it's going to look
ugly quick but it's all going to be
understandable so what this says is that
we have to account for
the reaction rate of fission from all
other energy neutrons inside our volume
from other energies and other angles and
account for every other possible energy
because they can all make fission happen
what else is missing in terms of
describing the number of neutrons made
from fission yep there's the number of
neutrons made provision so we have to
put in our Neutron multiplication factor
and in this case normalize think someone
had mentioned solid angle we normalize
over all possible angles with an over
4pi in there and this right here is the
fission term so this tells us the number
of neutrons gained in terms of a
reaction rate times the number of
neutrons for each of those reactions
times the probability that there just
happened to be born in the energy group
that we're tracking so is there any term
here that's unclear to folks yeah on the
first integral that's zero electron
volts because supposedly you could have
a neutron at zero evey which has a very
high cross section of that so it should
probably induce fission in reality there
might be some actual minimum temperature
but there is a nonzero probability that
you could have a neutron at rest it's
just not very large the top bound is
Emax whatever your maximum Neutron
energy is this is usually around 10 MeV
for most fission reactors that Emax is
going to be this point right here the
highest energy at which neutrons can be
born by any process and so this term
right here is going to serve as a
template for all the other gain and loss
terms so I think this is the hardest one
that we had to develop from the
beginning
now let's develop the term for let's
just go with external sources pretty
easy
there's gonna be some source making
neutrons it's something that you would
just impose like say alright I have a
californium source giving off this many
neutrons well then you know how many
neutrons that's giving off and that
one's done that's easy so we've done
fission we've done external now that
we've done fission let's tackle photo
fission so what would the photo fission
cross-section look like
it's going to look awfully similar so
what sort of things do you need to know
if it's a fission reaction well what do
we have up here to start reading things
off I heard a murmur was that yep so
you're gonna have to have some flux in
this case we want to know what's the
flux of gamma rays because photo fission
starts off with a gamma that ends up
with a fission and it's also going to be
in our volume it's going to matter what
the energy of those gammas is they'll
all be traveling in some direction at
some time what else do we need uh yeah
if we're gonna be going over all angles
yep you need the 4pi what else do we
have a reaction rate yet no well what's
missing that's right
we need a cross-section and in this case
instead of just fission or neutron
fission we'll put in the gamma fission
cross-section and so now we have a
reaction rate for a single reaction
we've got to integrate over all of our
gamma-ray energies over all angles over
our volume what else is missing
besides our D Omega de gamma D volume it
should look awfully similar because the
terms are basically exactly the same
with just different cross sections and
energies in there so what's missing
between the photo fission and the
neutron fission one sure there might be
some different birth spectrum for gammas
and there might be some different
multiplication factor for gammas between
neutron fission and photo fission but
these terms should look exactly the same
because in every case you're looking at
some reaction rate between either the
neutrons and fission or the gammas and
fission and you need to know at what
energy they're born how many are made
all the angles and integrate over all
the variables that we care about and
this is part of why I'm adding these
extra terms because they end up looking
all exactly the same it's the integral
of a reaction rate times some stuff
that's all that every single one of
these terms is going to be so we've got
photo fission
now let's tackle in scattering so how do
we represent scattering in the same way
that we represented fission what do we
start with inside the integral
reaction rate yes so we're going to have
some scattering cross-section and if
it's in scattering it means it's coming
from a different energy
hence the prime will have our flux and
here's where we're gonna bring in our
scattering kernel because there's some
probability that the neutron scatters in
from a different group and then we'll
have our D Omega D prime DV is this
complete yet
we've now accounted for one other energy
e prime now how do we account for all
possible other energies scattering into
our energy group yep again same
integrals we integrate over all possible
energies over all possible angles and
over our volume hopefully these terms
are looking very similar in every case
it's a volume angle energy integral of a
reaction rate and all that saying is
there's some rate that these reactions
are occurring which is either a gain
rate or a loss rate we integrate over
whatever volume energy and angle we're
tracking and that's all there is to it
so we've got in scattering now let's
tackle the ni n reactions there's only
going to be one little difference but I
want you guys to tell me what sort of
things are going to be the same as all
the other terms that we have here so
what do we start off with in this in the
inside the integral
a reaction rate how we write that yep a
cross-section there's going to be some
cross-section for let's call it an
n-by-n reaction as a function of energy
times a flux will be our normal
integrated over all angles all energies
and our volume so we have a reaction
rate what do we have to then integrate
that reaction right over to get all the
neutrons in
same things as everything else exactly
integrate over all possible energies
integrate over all possible angles
integrate over our volume looks quite
similar the only thing we haven't dealt
with is this I term right here because
there can be there are actually n to n
reactions + 3 n + 4 N and so on so there
are probabilities that let's say you in
goes one Neutron out comes three
neutrons but no fission actually
happened you just blast a few of them
out so I think all we'd really have to
do is sum over I equals 1 oh I'm sorry I
equals 2 because a neutron going in and
then the same Neutron going out that's
just scattering and what would be the
maximum probably 4 because the
probability of an increasing I or more
neutrons coming out gets lower and lower
as you go in fact these reactions don't
even turn on until the end-to-end
reaction turns on at around like 1 MeV
this one turns on and around like 5 MeV
this one turns on at like 12 MeV I was
just looking up these cross-sections
before class so if you have a reaction
that doesn't happen beyond your highest
Neutron energy you probably don't need
to worry about it but the reason I had
us write all these extra equations and I
think that the the t-shirt for this
department needs some updating to
include these extra terms because
they're all the same term it is in every
case it's an integral over all of our
stuff of a reaction rate
Dease tough times some multiplier every
single term in this equation follows the
exact same pattern so what I hope and I
would expect out of you guys is that if
I were to give you this table of
possible reactions you would be able to
recreate this neutron transport equation
using this template to know that every
single reaction is just multiplier times
integral of stuff of a reaction rate D
stuff where the reaction rate is just a
cross section times the flux that's all
there is to it not bad when you see that
everything follows the same pattern
right that's the basis behind most of
the hideous equations that you see in
all physics everywhere is if there are
additive or subtractive terms they
better be in the same units and so
they're going to follow some sort of a
similar template not too scary when you
think of it that way so let's now come
up with the lost terms I should have
planned these boards better keep these
ones here so we keep a template and
we'll have a - well how do we write the
anything reaction using this template
how many neutrons undergo a reaction
when one Neutron undergoes a reaction
yeah one so our multiplier is one we
don't have to worry about it we have our
integral of stuff so we'll have to
integrate over all possible volumes
angles and energy and what's on the
inside yep
total cross-section as a function of
energy times the flux DS stuff save time
so don't worry even though the boards
are laid out funny on the pictures of
the blackboard that will put on the
stellar site I'll Photoshop these and
arrange them so that they're all in
sequence and you can see everything and
then there's the last term to account
for that's the leakage term this one is
a little different it's the only one
that's a little different and in this
case we're going to say that our little
volume element also has a surface to it
and if the neutrons leave the surface
then they're go then they leave the
volume so in this case we'll have a
surface integral of our Neutron flouts
say our Neutron flux D s because there's
no reaction happening when neutrons just
move right they just go and so well we'd
also have to multiply by our normal
vector because every flux is going to
have a certain number of neutrons moving
in a certain direction let's say we were
tracking the flow of neutrons through
this surface right here and if we had a
flux going in exactly this direction
through this surface and this is the
normal vector in this case flux which is
a vector dotted with a normal vector is
just the flux which is to say that if
the flux and the normal vector are
aligned in the same way then every
Neutron going through the surface is
tracked as going through the surface to
take the opposite example what about the
situation where you have a surface here
and you have a mono directional flux of
neutrons in this direction and that is
your surface normal what does the flux
dotted with the surface normal vector
equal zero just a dot product between
the direction that your neutrons are
moving and the normal vector saying does
it go out of the surface at all so for
these two limiting cases in this case
the flux is just listed what is it the
number of neutrons leaving the surface
is the flux in this case no neutrons
leave the surface because they're not
actually going through the surface it's
a good time to mention again that these
units of flux are in neutrons per
centimeter squared per second which is
to say the number of particles traveling
through this area in centimeters squared
every second I know we've gone over it
before but I want you to keep these
units in mind because now they actually
have a little more physical significance
and that's why we have this flux times
normal vector DS that describes the
number of neutrons that get through the
surface the last thing we'll do because
everything else is a volume integral we
want this to be a volume integral
because we're going to simplify this in
terms of getting rid of all the volume
stuff we're going to use what's called
the divergence theorem I hear some
snickering because I remember this is
probably something that where you were
told in 1801 or eight - no - this exists
use it in a few problems moving on that
sound about right
this is
you actually use it so the divergence
theorem says that the integral of some
variable f D s through some volume
element of surface is the same as the
volume integral of how does this go del
dot F DV and this is going to be quite
important because one it gives us a
volume integral so this is a be a volume
integral of our del dot flux DV so now
everything's in the same units and if we
were to say forget about our little
volume element let's just assume an
infinite reactor every single volume
integral in terms instantly disappears
because we wrote these equations to be
identical for any DV anywhere inside
this reactor if the reactor is then
infinite then all of those volume terms
disappear and that's the first
simplification that we'll make in the
next class but right here on these five
boards we've developed the neutron
transport equation which is the absolute
most general highest escalated form of
how do you track neutrons through any
volume any direction any energy at any
time and we'll spend Thursday and Friday
simplifying this to something that we
can solve the other reason that we use
this divergence theorem is because we're
going to make an approximation this
crazy-looking thing right here we will
make an approximation called the
diffusion approximation where we assume
that neutrons are like a gas that just
diffuse away from each other and that's
gonna make solving this really really
easy it's gonna go from some
second-order differential or
differential integral equation to just
an equation that you can solve with
algebra yep
probably yep
overall II overall Omega and that flux
is gonna be of our e omega t absolutely
just to make sure everything's in the
same units every term has a fairly
similar template the only difference is
leakage there's no reaction here every
single other term constitutes a reaction
and they all follow this template so I
will stop here because it is 5 of C if
anyone has any quick questions on what
you've got here I'll make sure to get
all of this on the board images so you
guys can take a look at it and I'll
project it up on the screen so that we
can make some simplifications based on
what we see here on Thursday yeah the
neutron birth spectrum says that if you
have any old fission event what's the
probability of those neutrons being born
at different energies what this says is
that they're born between 1 and 10 MeV
with a peak at around 2 MeV but if you
want to track the number of neutrons in
every energy group you need to know
where they begin good question so if any
of the terms here are unclear what they
physically mean because that's what I'm
most interested in you guys knowing
please do ask either on Piazza on email
on Thursday yeah the big end and the
little end which one the curse of one or
this one
okay the little end and the non cursive
one little n is the number of neutrons
in a volume at a certain energy going in
a direction at a certain time big n
right here is just number density number
of atoms per centimeter cubed cursive n
is the number of neutrons at an energy
in a volume we don't care where they're
going and the reason I write these terms
up here is we are going to switch from
lowercase to capital or angular ly
dependent to angular ly independent by
making a simple approximation to say we
don't care what direction they're going
we just care if they're there but in
real complex neutron physics problems
like the one solved in the computational
reactor physics group you need to know
all the angles and you need to know the
probability or the cross section that a
neutron coming in at this angle leaves
at that angle and imparts a certain
energy because they're all different the
purposes of this class I just want you
to know that they exist and the first
thing we will do is simplify them away
but this way you'll be fully prepared
for 22:05 and a lifetime of reactor
physics if you so choose who here's done
a year up in the computational reactor
physics group just one okay I recommend
more they they tend to be the biggest
group in the department they've got like
twenty grad students and probably more
your ops than that so try it out it's
what makes us us us nukes right is
neutrons and tracking them to ridiculous
proportions okay definitely wanna let
you guys go cuz it's one of so I'll see
you all on Thursday